so I'll say it again when you want to
say something important punctuate it
with silence in this video we're going
to be talking about the highest leverage
Habit in all of speaking and that's
pausing but don't brush this away
because this is the hardest habit to
learn this is all part of the
fundamental Series so we've covered
confidence in the first video we covered
musicality in the second video and we're
really covering the skills that break
down speaking into the highest leverage
habits and pausing is the biggest one of
them all because when you pause you feel
better but not at first at first pausing
feels uncomfortable it feels kind of
awkward and it doesn't feel natural and
so we don't do it but the problem is
that without pausing all of our bad
speaking habits tend to come to life
often times we'll find that people would
rather speak without knowing what
they're saying than taking a step back
and thinking in silent why because it's
more comfortable to keep speaking than
it is to stop speaking and that's the
problem the problem is that it's
uncomfortable to stop and take a breath
but it's so important I mean think about
the example of driving it's much easier
to drive when you know where you're
going when you have a navigation system
where you've checked the map and you
have the directions in your mind but you
know that feeling where you don't know
where you're going but you're still
driving it's much more stressful you're
trying to navig
and drive at the same time it becomes
dangerous the safe thing to do is to
just pull over for for a minute check
the map oh yeah I need to go there and
then get back into it and then when you
get back into it knowing where you're
going the driving feels automatic you
can start singing while you're driving
you can have the music playing you're
paying attention but it's also kind of
on autopilot and that's what we want our
speaking to be we want speaking this
flow oriented subconscious natural
process that we do we want it to feel
easy effortless on autopilot and it can
but it only can when we know where we're
going because without the clarity of the
destination our attention is busy
navigating and when we're thinking and
speaking at the same time our brain is
trying to do too much at once and we
start to get into these little
collisions maybe we ramble maybe we
start using filler words um and um so uh
it's just our brain going come on idea
come on idea where am I going where am I
going we're in the momentum of speaking
and we haven't learned the habit of
unwinding that and
stopping but stopping is excellent it's
such a gift for your audience stopping
allows people to really hear what you
have to say in fact if you want a
tactical piece of advice whenever you
say something important stop
talking what happens
well people Replay that last important
sentence in their head in the silence
the silence perks up their attention
they go whoa that's a signal maybe I
should lean in and listen and when
there's nothing in that space they
replay the last thing that you said and
it really lets it sink in so I'll say it
again when you want to say something
important punctuate it with
silence and let it sink in now you don't
have to use it for such a dramatic
effect that's more of a tactical tip
that's not why we're doing this but we
are doing this to emphasize the the
contrast to emphasize that if everything
is said in a speed that is rushed
nothing will stand out sometimes we do
need to stop speaking in order to
punctuate that hey what I just said
really
matters but more importantly we need to
learn the habit of knowing when to pull
over and check directions because our
speaking is like a train of thought
you're on a bullet train as soon as you
know what you're talking about off you
go and speaking becomes this automatic
process but no matter who you are you're
going to lose your train of thought
eventually or it's just going to end and
then what well then you got to think
about where do I go next what do I want
to say next in that presentation you're
answering a question that you didn't
expect and suddenly you're answering it
and you you explain that idea but you're
not done talking but you also don't know
where you're going next what do you do
in that moment
the healthy thing is to pause to take a
breath and in that silence the idea
arises Clarity AR the dsts the
philosophy that's all about going with
the flow the dsts believe that Clarity
comes from this place called no mind
this place behind the thinking brain I
mean let's face it we don't know know
where our thoughts come from do we try
to think of thoughts or do they
spontaneously arise in our awareness
it's a little too deep for this video
but in my opinion thoughts arise
organically thoughts arise when we
create spaciousness for them thoughts
arrive when we trust that thoughts so
part of the habit of pausing is
developing the trust that even when I
don't know where I'm going if I take a
break that idea will be there for me it
might take a second or two or three or
five but it's worth it it's worth
staying in that silent and being
thoughtful in order to really connect
with where you want to go next because
then you're going to speak with
certainty you're going to speak with
Clarity and the audience is going to
appreciate it but here's the problem
silence feels uncomfortable internally
silence feels a lot longer than it looks
it's the theory of relativity perfectly
encapsulated silence feels longer than
it looks so a 3 second pause will feel
like a 10-second pause a 1-second pause
will still feel like a 5-second pause
it's really strange but we see it all
the time if you're under pressure in
front of people all eyes on you and you
feel like you're losing your train
thought and you stop speaking to think
the first thought in your head goes
everyone's looking
the next thought in your head goes they
must think I don't know what I'm talking
about the third thought goes uhoh I'm
blank and there's this unrest in the
mind there's an anxiousness like come on
brain please save me please please
please and that anxiousness is what's
preventing Clarity it's what's
preventing the thoughts to arise
naturally so part of what we do at Ultra
speaking is unwinding this tense anxious
habit of hurrying
this tense anxious desire to always know
what we're talking about and we want to
create a healthier relationship we want
to create a truthful relationship and
the truthful relationship is that there
will be moments where you know what
you're talking about and there will be
moments where you don't and that's
natural that's how it's supposed to be
and in the moments where you don't in
the moments where you find yourself
losing your train of thought losing
Clarity rambling feeling like I'm not as
connected to what I was saying those are
the moments that we must remember to
pause and by the way we do this with our
friends all the time we do this with our
family so naturally it's in the moments
where we feel pressure that things
change that we feel higher pressure to
do the opposite we where we feel rushed
and so let's internalize a few ideas and
wrap this up idea number one is that a
pause feels longer than it looks
meaning it's going to feel uncomfortable
so you're not going to want to do it but
the truth is it's not that long people
forget about it the moment you start
talking again number two pausing is a
gift to your listeners meaning that when
you say something and then you pause
afterwards people digest it they
appreciate the
space they want to reflect on what you
said and when we're talking all the time
it's really hard to digest on the fly so
you're giving them a gift to just take a
little
breather and number three pausing is a
flush for the mind it relaxes the body
it it gets the shoulders to drop it it
really is a tool to reset the mind and
allow for new better deeper ideas to
come in and if we don't create that
space then we'll always stay on the same
wavelength that we started and that
implies that where we start is the right
destination and we don't know that we
don't always get the best idea at first
ideas evolve as we talk them out as we
think as we breathe so creating that
space to breathe allows for ideas to
improve one question you might be asking
hey Michael I get it but every time I
pause I get interrupted someone jumps in
and I never get to finish my train of
thought I get it some people are big
interrupts but that's the reality in my
experience people don't get interrupted
when they pause with confidence when you
pause without confidence when you don't
trust your own pause when you feel it's
awkward you are likely to get
interrupted it's a little catch 202
that's why we need to practice the habit
of pausing with confidence believing
that we deserve to take the space to
think because it benefits everybody and
when you have pausing as a habit when
it's a natural part of your speaking
when you're able to go on a train of
thought and flow with it and then also
remember to take a breath there's a
natural musicality but more importantly
there's an un
hurriedness there's a presence to you
there's a groundedness and this is what
we call Executive presence there's this
there's a an a relaxed ease you're no
longer anxiously searching for the next
idea you're no longer rushing to get all
your words across in a short amount of
time you're you're taking your time and
taking your time means that you believe
you deserve to take the time and space
to speak you're worthy of that and a lot
of people don't have that conviction in
themselves they don't have that belief
it takes time to develop and that's why
we say that only confident people pause
because pausing takes confidence it
really does to say nothing in front of
everybody and have them wait for you
takes confidence but we have to remember
that it's a gift to everyone that it
will improve your speaking and most
importantly you already do this with the
people you feel most EAS with so it's
just learning to do that in environments
where we feel a little bit intimidated
or a little bit of pressure and that's
why we need to practice in simulated
environments we need to practice Under
Pressure we need to make pausing habit
and that's what we do in the
fundamentals course we make it a habit
we make it a part of our speaking so
that you don't have to think to remember
to pause it becomes a natural part of
your Cadence and when that happens a lot
of internal sh gifts happen as well you
feel like you belong more you feel like
you deserve to share your voice you feel
like you deserve to take up space and
you feel more relaxed because that's
what pausing ultimately does so it's
hard it's difficult the most difficult
skill in my experience most people don't
do it enough some people don't do it at
all but at the end of the day those who
build comfort in the pause those who are
able to stay in the silence think
breathe and wait for clarity those are
the people who end up communicating the
clearest communicating with the most
confidence and those are the people who
enjoy speaking because they take the
pressure off themselves and they're able
to relax into the flow of things which
is what speaking is all about